l'Angleterre préparait son geste
politique depuis longtemps le port lors
des matchs d'un brassard multicolore
contre la discrimination en appui à la
communauté LGBT réprimée au Qatar 6
autres sélections dont celle allemande
devait emboîter le pas mais les menaces
de la FIFA imposées des sanctions et des
cartons jaunes pour les joueurs les ont
fait reculer le capitaine anglais porte
le brassard noir approuvé par la FIFA
sur laquelle est inscrit pas de
discrimination
escalade
la sélection danoise tout en noir à
l'entraînement un maillot unique pour
dénoncer l'exploitation des travailleurs
migrants qui ont construit les stades de
soccer et autres infrastructures au
Qatar la FIFA interdit au Danemark de
porter ses maillots lors de ses parties
la Fédération danoise c'est entretenue
avec les autorités du Qatar pour aider à
améliorer la situation des droits de la
personne
pas de coût d'éclat pour le Canada le
gouvernement Trudeau dit avoir de bonnes
relations avec le Qatar il mise sur le
dialogue une rencontre avec les
autorités catary et prévu cette semaine
dans un stade vide en Allemagne lors du
coup d'envoi de la Coupe du Monde geste
décla pour dénoncer les abus des droits
de la personne la pression
internationale sur le Qatar continue
aussi à l'étranger
tout le mal causé par cette Coupe du
Monde est inexcusable c'est honteux
affirme l'organisateur